okay so we're just working on tension
are hit with our some very key basics
that you're missing because you're doing
the body mechanics your way thought it
was our return okay so we're gonna take
three things and apply help a whole lot
of chambers so the first one is the
connection and then the second one is
the Mars spiral and the third one will
be the entry okay so on the first one
you don't just open like you can't have
the centerline just be Afridi okay
that's not the technique
so the technique is first going to bring
them up towards heaven and then turn
them and drop them towards right Tenshi
not giving me seven in her throat but
it's not just a matter of one hand down
what had up
remember the Dallas principle of
concentric truth if it's one hand down
one hand up is also going to be up and
down throughout okay
so first they go up then they go down so
how do I do this I can't lift my hands
because I can't put the articulation
point in your shoulders see that but
when you think up you go hands up we
have to solve for the solution in
different way so my elbows are going to
drop you see that and once my elbows
drop I have that angle if you want it
when you brought your hand up so keep
your breath when you bring your hand up
you see that elbow yeah I'm gonna do it
the other way I'm gonna drop my elbow
you see that
so I drop I try to make my hands as
still as they are I drop my elbows and
then I can lift into her so drop my
elbows don't go back to this drop my
elbows and lift into her so to lift into
her it's the same spiral you you do with
your whole arm like you're going to do
shomenuchi the shomenuchi doesn't go
like this right the hand rotates the
wrist rotates the elbow rotate and the
shoulder rotates do you understand
so that's why I mean when I say our lips
so I lower my elbows and then I start
the lid and then you have her okay so
here lower and then the rotation starts
okay let's try that part drumming so
some some ways of helping you I draw I
don't want to do the wrist cycle and the
elbow cycle in the way that I'm trying
to come out like I'm escaping do you
understand that I'm going to film a grip
that's what I wanted to drop and fill or
grip fill the grip do you understand
at the same time I don't feel her grip
where I keep my hands where my wrists
are you see the alignment that's
incorrect so I I don't it's not a
lifting at the elbows you see that I'm
coming out aren't I okay and my hands
are coming back towards me you see the
distance to my torso so it's more of a
forward miss you see that so it's
totally different because I'm coming out
and it'll be noticed because your hand
is in the same line with your wrists and
your forearm so I draw and then whoa am
i filling that grip up and lifting it
and I lift like I always do from here
down Oh get out of your shoulders set
okay let's go okay so I don't want to be
out here there's a plane here and I'm
staying on that plane there's going to
be an energy that's going this way so
she comes up and it's going when I when
I yield my elbows tend to come in so I
can't really keep my arms here and drop
my elbows too much without bringing the
hands back a lot so when I bring my
elbows in I can get underneath and my
hands aren't coming too far out of that
plane do you understand so do the two
ways for this point so I'm dropping my
elbows this is my
and I drop my elbows in they don't
really come so we're just going to give
her a little second point is there's an
intrigue remember I don't want to open
the center line okay so we're gonna
demonstrate that why you can make her go
that way
not just up okay so elbows oh hey try
[Music]
this elbow comes down to create that
harming and then the thumb moves now I
can't go anymore
you see that it goes till it completes
its cycle and then when I use the elbow
it's not that it hinges so that it said
that elbow so I drop the elbow then the
thumb and then the elbow starts its
cycle which is not this but this okay
and once that elbow starts to move
so elbow down now I can't make it go
anymore
see it reaches a tight
and it tells me to get the elbow to
start moving here's the thing once the
elbow starts moving see that you guys
will to go mom down with the hand and so
if you do move the elbow so some of you
are going here
here and then you leave the elbow there
and you think you're moving it by an
engine and you don't want to hinge it
okay then those who are moving moving
the elbow right will leave the hand and
now you have you're gonna have the
straight wrist you see that because you
didn't keep it going so I want my elbow
to kinda have an energy where it is in
front of my hat these you see that not
even with mine so I go underneath oh do
you see that and it keeps going okay I
just taking that technique and using it
like a hundredth of a second okay I'm
not using it but I'm using it to bring
him in and then they keep his shoulders
and people live then the then the other
hand movement is to take that whole
bring it in lifting them shoulders going
by and rotate it on an axis you
understand
so I know what I'm going this so it's
just very small he comes it and then we
rotate okay all right
you're not high they often tilted and
located right here have no idea so let's
look at West let's step out of that girl
okay and one arm from here because he's
leaning on me now do you see that that's
why I could project Meyer so one arm
from there is going to go like this
so he's gonna disappear going here
there's your figure eight that's your
same club that I hashed out he goes this
way and we're here that's your Sophie
not here right Eva this way the you
loaded mom is using your balance and you
take away that hand not like this right
you see that you have to make the
pattern it's this way
this way then then we'll finish this way
so I'd load him up boom and I go this
way and this way
this hand cannot contradict that it
loads him up then it's gonna disappear
not by going yet like the other hand but
by going up inside you pay attention
this hand is making his body do that
same pattern here now I tilted it so
connection that now he's on me and now I
just reconcile all of that with my two
hands but this is Aikido so my body does
that right these are patterns are just
doing this the heart shape everything
else happens because my body is charging
should enter got it so I'm always just
doing this and I make you my body
move so if you if you go here and you go
like this is gonna look kind of here so
I know my body won't anything see how my
body is moving right back dry tendencies
so the second elements we're getting to
work on is the arm so you guys are doing
something
I'm going to try to describe it in
multiple ways you're making your hand go
on a circle and your elbows going on the
strip
that is like to circumcised one here and
there's one here and you're going like
this so you do the technique and then
you're going
if I use this plane here and I make a
circle it'll be a Halfmoon onto this
plane that's not what I wanted to do is
imagine like there's a ink spot here
like an ink roller okay and I wanted not
to touch that part and then be on the
other side of that same plane I wanted
to travel all around my arm see that so
it's like a coiling snake
so however I start I start let's say I'm
here at the end I'm going to end up on
the other side outside
so I go one you see I'm coming on my
other side there when I when I hit here
this outside
this part is touching the joke not the
inside of my arms so I'm going wrong
tracing that line all the way around do
you see that you guys see that I'm going
to touch the inside of my arm
you see that okay when I stay like this
square plane shoulders shoulders hip in
alignment you're gonna feel tightness
you know you do want the tour but it's
gonna be too much like oh that's gonna
get tight right and then when I turn I
took off that you see that when I come
back it's on and I turn the hold you see
that that little hip shift is what we're
going to do in the third element we're
gonna correct but right now I want you
to kind of eat roll a snake coiling
around your arm where you end up with
the outside of that elbow at the top
right and touching the joke oh you see
that
Hey not like this
not part way right you see that okay try
so I'm not making a circle where do you
let's just round it off to a foot I'm
not making a circle a foot away from me
and another equals circle six inches
away that's not what I'm doing I want to
keep the yin and the young going at
every level so as you as you watch this
this is what makes it a spiral so as my
arm this arm is more the hand is more in
dental elbow you see if you see that
okay so as it starts to move the hand is
going out do you see that and the elbow
is going in okay and as I come around
the elbow is in and the hand is out
they're not on the same plane as the
elbow the hand is starting to go up the
elbows going down did you see that as
the hand is coming in the elbow is going
out as the hand is starting to come down
the elbow is going up you see that so
they're not doing the same thing I have
a spiral and they're always harmonizing
those yin and Yan aspects they're not
doing the same thing it's not a young
arm or a yin arm it's both at different
points okay
do you understand so lose this stuff
right
long and for this throw this inner pump
this outer part has got to be the top
inner part at the end of the technique
okay so this is wrong this is wrong this
is wrong this is wrong I don't care
about the throat I care about the
movement the movement do you understand
I'm going to use that in a million
different ways even just at a
conditioning level right I might just
hit you with a oh but it will have
decades of that torquing and it will not
be the same as somebody who didn't spend
decades doing it you got it
so this spiral is helping me torque all
of those tissues and condition them and
as I'm torquing them I'm reducing the
lack of integrity in the joints and in
the tissues okay so try to keep that
going giving y'all standing up on the
jogo working on the second elevator bar
I don't care if you get the first
settlement do you wanna do you want to
do like that okay if you if you want to
work it his head is now the joke none of
you not the Joe over you all just trace
around that unit so I'd not not get his
head over I just traced it around okay
so that's so at the end that part right
if he still up is gonna touch him
they're not going to go like this with C
they go around so around the energy okay
let's try it like that you guys are
using your arm it's a sewing nephew item
why did we use the arms for what do they
make sense we already did it literally
they're turning the axis that's all
they're doing got it
you guys are trying to knock them down
so what happens is like once you feel
that then you're like gotcha but
now you're not doing that yogi what I
mean the tissue training and it doesn't
actually work if they're bigger than you
you're gonna get Jack if they have a
weapon you're gonna get jacked right so
you have to discipline yourself just to
work the pattern don't do the throw do
the pattern and the throw just happens
okay so I will I will steal him all I
felt do you see I feel that I feel him
right there
do you guys see that stand up so you can
see you see that I'm not gonna do the
Harlem Globetrotter and right pump the
ball from the bicep to my wrists I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna keep the pattern
going the pattern right oh he fell up I
don't care I'm not gonna go here he fell
up it doesn't matter I keep okay the
throw doesn't happen with that the throw
happens with my head right here right
here this is the throat
[Music]
okay so he's here right it's not
knocking down this it's displacing this
that's the throat so all my arm was
doing was tilting oh I just do the
pattern and this has been before you for
decades
some of you I don't I'm not throwing
them I'm just I like to say I'm creating
in a geometry for falling okay so I
don't need a bracing angle or even a hip
rotation to get the throat it happened
the person was already following do you
understand so and why is that important
because that means that I have redundant
elements and you need redundant elements
when ever you go you try to be marshal
thing things fail okay so you could you
should be able to do the throw without
even entering ok so then and then might
that means therefore my stance is not
really the throw in terms of the
acceleration do you get that so I'm not
accelerating this oh I don't need a
bracing angle I don't need a hit
rotation right what I want to do is to
get this hip I create that opening and
the head is going this way his feet are
going up in the air so I'm rotating that
and I'm going to now shorten the
rotation which means you will have less
capacity to spin out of the technique
here so if I if he's here and I do like
a big thing he hadn't kind of turned
over this way but if I do it work I'm
right in here and I just spin this part
it's very hard for him to turn belly
down you get that you can't you can't
turn belly down so I'm gonna I got it
tilting and then I'm gonna change the
axis of rotation with my body and that
will help this thing as I rotate around
his center I'm also moving his center to
space you see that so his center is
moving through space and now it's
spinning around itself on my hip and you
can't go belly down okay so it's this
this is the action
so let's this is your drill you're going
to put a foot and a diagonal and bring
the other foot here and you're going to
push it Brown this leg pushing you will
have more weight on this leg at that you
see that so I'm not going this way right
I'm not going that way and then turn i'm
already turn
boom already turn so your guy is down
right he gets in that position I put
this foot look where do you put that
foot that foot is going to be behind his
other foot so that this foot can move
out in the trajectory where that foots
pushing okay so if this foot is here and
I try to get behind us foot this foots
not pushing all right do you understand
so this way has to be it can be a little
shy like I got some of this heel you see
that that will get my hip even closer
but it can't be to such a degree that is
no longer pushing anymore so and back
and then I'm close enough that my hip
will make his hip move got it but I'm
going to do that when he's here so I
just moving in okay try that
[Music]
okay so let's say I'm doing free
shipping all right this is the exact
same thing so if I move my hip towards
their armpit you see that that's a big
rotation and no displacement okay I have
to come right by the hip right by the
hip do you see that you guys remember
that okay so when you go to the thigh
it's the same thing you can't come
towards the armpit you're gonna rotate
them a lot with no displacement you're
going to get counter and you're not
hitting the back of the head on the
street so you miss the target
they're gonna roll okay so I have two
right there right there
my hip goes did you see that you can't
think of it this way right if she turns
towards me chili cheesy burger buddy
she's right in for the cookie night
that's how close I am okay so I'm going
to hit that your stance is so unstable
right now right yeah does everybody
understand that yes remember them up and
they're turning it doesn't take much so
I'm going to come in and hit that here
boom okay try it again
so his body's coming there it's being
brought up is starting to be tilted I'm
gonna take his head this way and now I'm
making his center moving space and
continue that tilt did you get it okay
so well wait a my foot enters it doesn't
enter like this this is gonna push him
out of the technique right if it doesn't
interlock this and then does not turn
yeah that's going in with that arm okay
so I need you guys have missed this my
foot enters for the hip you see that and
this knee follows the rule of the nu
Miyoshi I bring my knee to my toes
that's my that's the rotation that you
guys think is that you see that or that
people do worse that I'm moving in just
like you war and then boom that's it
I bring the knee to the toes because
that's what is now activated for forward
progress okay if you pass that you're
here and you pass that your weight is
going to come backwards the other foot
you're gonna have a weak structure here
with the knee here so you're not
actually entering you're actually going
out of the technique so you're going to
do the same thing you move in and boom
there's a tiny little shift of the knee
forward because the hip is connected to
the ankle on the knee that's the hip
rotation that you are been trying there
so we're here and I'm moving in put
we're gonna bring the arm in I'm going
to bring the pointy snake
here this place
[Music]
so now I'm just working as his head to
hit your honor your discipline keeps the
powder but don't let it attract you to
shoving it down go ahead sir thank you
doing
[Music]
so let's just focus on there yeah it's
gonna go
[Music]
not straighten it create the initial
angle cancellation you see right here
you see that I'm on the outside of the
elbow the shoulders right there okay not
see I might be inside okay so it's one
and what's happening is you're anxious
to get to that and you don't want to be
you want to go here okay all right keep
going keep loading the hip
the spiral don't do yiridi me not yet
do this new time you're pushing his head
right get the coiling snake around your
arm right
[Music]
you don't do one and does the other get
rid of the idea on the north style of 12
design you want this thing rotating okay
don't come back to the ball from where
he came to rawhide that'll bring in the
armpit
the fight has rotated watch your head
Hey all right let's stop there